and Moscow says early results from
so-called referendums held in occupied
Ukraine show most voters favor joining
Russia the Kremlin is expected to use
the outcome to Annex four regions Kevin
its allies describe the votes as sham
ballots and are refusing to recognize
the results
dropping a vote Into The Ballot Box
should mean having a say in one's future
that not many ukrainians believe that's
what happened in so-called referendums
staged in four russian-held regions of
Ukraine
first results showed overwhelming
support for joining Russia
cave in the west have already said they
would not recognize the outcome of a
ballot that Ukraine says was in some
cases conducted at gunpoint
there's a small number of people who
have to put something like that
agreement mark on the ballot and why
because a man comes to every house with
a rifle and asks them to vote what
should people do when an armed person
comes to their home they're forced to
sign the ballot
a video from Mario poll shared by the
Ukrainian city government in Exile shows
armed soldiers following election
workers into residential buildings
a warning by Ukrainian authorities that
people will face criminal punishment if
they vote prompted some to leave
and others to hide behind closed doors
[Music]
Ukrainian leadership and its Western
allies see the referendums as a pretext
for the Kremlin to Annex the four
regions luhansk Donetsk zaparisa and
Herson
many ordinary ukrainians think the same
it's illegal they're worse than fascists
simply unbearable
in a chilling warning last week Vladimir
Putin said he would be ready to use
nuclear weapons to protect territory he
considers part of the Russian Federation
with the war escalating continuously
over the last few months many ukrainians
left their homes long before Moscow
staged its so-called referendums on
their future those who stayed faced the
likelihood they'll now have to live as
citizens of Russia and perhaps even
become Fighters for its Army
let's take a closer look at this with DW
correspondent Nick Connelly in the
Ukrainian Capital welcome Nick picking
up on that last point from the report
what do you think would people in
occupied regions of Ukraine fight for
Russia
well certainly we have already seen
signs that Russia is trying to recruit
people in these regions so far with the
promise of money and other company
occasionally there have been reports of
duress and kind of pressure applied to
these people there's definitely a sense
that Russia would rather recruit people
from donets from luhans can maybe even
support Egypt other parts of occupied
Ukraine rather than risking the kind of
kind of social conflict we are seeing in
the mobilization in Russia itself as for
people being willing to fight against
Ukraine against their own country it's
you know often going to be a question of
you know how much Freedom they have to
choose how much real option they have
we're hearing about people being forced
to take passports even before these
votes anyone working for the government
teachers doctors civil servants
basically being given the option of
taking a Russian passport or losing
their job and their only way of
surviving so um this definitely is a
prospect that is very scary and we as
with voting in this so-called referenda
we're seeing people just trying to sit
it out hiding from the authorities the
Russian occupational authorities there
sitting in their summer houses trying to
stay at apartments where they're not
registered where the authorities
wouldn't know where to look for them and
hope that somehow this passes them by
and that something similar happens as
Ukraine was able to do in kharkiv where
they were able to push Russian front
lines back uh you know dozens of
kilometers in the space of a few days in
the hope that would then kind of solve
the problem for them right so when the
results are eventually declared and as
we presume the vote goes to a yes well
do you will residents still have a
chance to escape
we've had reports from Hassan region
already today that basically it is now
impossible to leave at least directly to
Ukrainian held territory in other parts
of the country the picture isn't quite
as clear but definitely Russia is not
making it easy for people to leave to
Ukrainian Health territory with NES or
any guarantee of safety there are
extraordinary stories of people having
to do kind of thousands of kilometers
Journeys traveling into Russian occupied
Crimea or across from Donetsk into
Russia proper and then traveling all the
way uh through either Georgia into
turkey and getting back to Ukraine that
way or through Belarus trying to get
into Lithuania or Poland so people
sometimes traveling thousands of
kilometers just to get you know 50 100
kilometers down the road into Ukrainian
Hill territory near to where they came
from right and now the world is holding
its breath to see how Russia would
defend these annexed regions
well that's definitely the threat we've
been hearing from pretty top level
people including Lana Putin uh in Moscow
in recent days that basically yes if
they then recognize these territories as
Russia proper they would then be able to
use the threat of nuclear retaliation if
you know Ukraine were to try and regain
these regions by force
um I think so far there's not too much
in the way of credence there's not the
real belief that this is for real
um I think there is and so far no sign
that Russia has significantly brought
its nuclear forces somehow into a
greater state of Readiness but
definitely it is a very dangerous
situation and we've seen Russia's
willingness to escalate over those you
know fighting near those huge nuclear
power stations in South Ukraine both of
which have had you know rockets explode
on their perimeters and there is a sense
really that uh you know this is
basically Russia's last chance it's
losing on the battlefield it doesn't
seem able to really replenish its
supplies of weapons given the sanctions
given its you know lack of personnel and
now basically the big the big threat the
big kind of nuclear uh kind of uh
elephant in the room is the one last
thing that they hope will at least if
not intimidate Ukraine but then force
people in Europe who've been supporting
Ukraine to think twice and maybe put
pressure on Kiev to make some kind of
compromised deal okay thank you for that
uh JW correspondent Nick Conley in key
one of the Lesser reported aspects of
this war is this effect on women and
girls in Ukraine and around the world so
let's bring in ASA Regner she's
assistant to Secretary General of the
United Nations and Deputy executive
director of un women she joins us from
New York welcome to DW and let's start
in Ukraine explain to us how the the war
is affecting women and girls differently
to men and boys
thank you so much for for having me well
uh this uh the war is devastating
obviously on everyone but we can see for
example that since women had lower
incomes than men to start with their
food insecurity and power poverty is
increasing more than men's uh we see
that the increased food prices have the
same had that effect on on women that
they are often seen as responsible for
food and cooking and so on as in many
countries and therefore the police Pride
the higher prices have a great impact on
their on their poverty rates
we also know that 90 almost of those who
have fled Ukraine uh during the war are
women with children and we know that
there is great risk unfortunately for
trafficking and other forms of
exploitation for example I would say a
forced
forced pornography and different kinds
of of sexual exploitation of women and
and girls
we also know of documented cases of
violence sexual violence against women
in Ukraine by Russian soldiers so there
are many different ways that women are
affected in a very very concerning way
by the war yeah I did want to ask you
specifically about women in those areas
of of Ukraine that are occupied by
Russians and this is the the threat of
sexual violence particularly is it
yes that's that is one a very big
concern uh that there has been or there
is an ongoing investigation that is
mandated by the Human Rights Council in
Geneva and they came out with the first
report on Friday where they document uh
and um several cases of sexual violence
against women and girls and and even to
me uh who works with this on a daily
basis all over the world they're very
upsetting information in that report and
obviously it is important that the UN
and others really try our best for
justice for women and girls I I want to
also point out that although women are
both victims of violence and other uh
hardship during the war they're also
extraordinary leaders and they are often
those who support other women and people
with big needs in the countryside
maybe people with disabilities who can't
move easily and they actually also are
in dialogue with us about the recovery
of Ukraine of course also together with
the government of Ukraine nice that's
very clear and um
more generally your report talks about
the problems being faced by women and
girls being invisible what what do you
mean by that
uh that as always I mean they in in
terms of War obviously everybody is
affected but we might hear more about
what happens to to to most of all men
because uh the war is fought by men and
it is important to highlight what is
actually happening to women and children
in these situations and uh what strikes
me the most is that women are both
really suffering the effects of War but
they're also doing incredible Deeds for
others in terms of highlighting other
other people's needs for example Ukraine
is a war zone with a big percentage of
elderly people which we actually haven't
really seen this way before
and that is a group elderly women is a
group that is not necessarily visible in
Wars understood thank you so much for
joining us as a Regner assistant un
Secretary General and Deputy executive
director of un women
thank you so much for having me